je veux l'adresse de cet abri cléville
trouver là moi excusez moi si j'osais je
vous demanderais c'est toujours gênant
je n'ai rien personnellement contre vous
mais je me fais une règle de ne jamais
sortir avec mes collègues alors merci
non je vous demanderais de ne plus vous
adressez à moi sur ce tout au bien sûr
voyant une légère différence une raison
pourquoi je vous parlerai aucune raison
c'est vrai je vois pas si nous allions à
la fabrique de peinture second on peut y
aller c'est à régler l'impasse que
c'était un peu tendu l'un de vous deux
sont en mesure crois que c'est tout est
arrangé à mener je veux surtout pas s'en
priver
allons-y fabrique de peinture elle sort
pas avec ses collègues passé